quando ho iniziato a occuparmi di
artigianato quasi sette od otto anni fa
parlare di artigianato sembrava una cosa
molto vecchia gli artigiani erano quelle
persone che facevano delle cose che
servivano non erano una categoria nobile
siamo in un paese dove tutti ci chiamano
avvocato ingegnere dottore signor
qualcosa non è abbastanza
un artigiano non ha un appellativo non
ha un genere per cui erano visti come le
cose che insomma non non erano
indispensabili alla nostra vita
poi è venuta la crisi la crisi la crisi
è stata importante è stata importante
perché ha fatto sì che abbiamo
cominciato a cercare a ricercare nella
dispensa nelle nostre origini nella
nostra storia quelle cose che sapevamo
fare sul serio
quelle cose peraltro che tutti gli altri
ci riconoscono non parlo solo
dell'italia
si dice che l'italia il paese del fatto
a mano è il paese del del made in italy
appunto ma questa per fortuna è una
grandissima capacità che hanno tutti
artigiani lo siamo tutti lo sono tutti i
paesi ognuno alle proprie ricchezze
ognuno alle proprie tradizioni ognuno
alla propria cultura
io sono architetto quando mi sono
laureata quando studiavo pensavo di fare
ponti grandi strutture perché mi
piacevano molto di più le fabbriche più
delle case le strutture poi da lì ho
capito che la mia passione invece
l'hanno proprio il lavoro la storia del
lavoro quello che facevano gli uomini e
ho cominciato a lavorare a queste arsen
kraft in italia non si sapeva proprio
cosa fosse gli altri paesi invece già
lavoravano su queste cose lavoravano
dalla quasi dalla rivoluzione
industriale noi siamo molto molto in
ritardo su questo settore siamo in
ritardo perché purtroppo quando sono
cominciati grandi le grandi esposizioni
le grandi occasioni di incontro per gli
artigiani l'italia non era neanche
ancora un paese
ho cominciato a lavorare all'artigianato
pur essendo architetto ho ritrovato
nella moda la filiera totale il mondo in
cui l'italia il paese in cui si va dal
disegno fino alla produzione è il paese
dove vengono tutti a produrre è
importantissimo
avere la consapevolezza di queste
capacità
purtroppo però noi spesso abbiamo
sbagliato abbiamo fatto il verso ad
altre situazioni più industrializzate
l'industrializzazione c'è un po ibernato
l'abbiamo vissuta sempre con una sorta
di complesso non dicevamo quello che
sapevamo fare perché se facevamo vedere
che eravamo capaci di farci un vestito
da solo voleva dire che non ce lo
potevamo comprare
quindi questo lavoro quando ha iniziato
a trovato molte difficoltà ho inventato
un progetto cinque anni fa che si chiama
ahi ahi vuol dire artisanal intelligence
ovviamente fa il verso ad artifici all
intelligence di spielberg e si muove su
vari territori di ricerca di studio di
analisi del territorio di
caratteristiche di capacità in tutto
questo tempo che oramai appunto sono più
di cinque o sei anni ho visto tante
storie alcune storie bellissime
anzi devo dire di grande successo
ho conosciuto ragazzi che pensavano di
essere artisti pensavano di aver trovato
un lavoro invece poi hanno completamente
cambiato strada perché li ho messi in
contatto con degli artigiani hanno
capito altre potenzialità sono nati
quelli che si chiamano in questo momento
gli ibridi
delle figure che sono minotauri metà una
cosa metà un'altra
in questo modo trovano maggiore
applicazione di quello che può essere il
loro il loro lavoro e la loro vita
ho insegnato parecchio ho insegnato in
una facoltà che si chiama disegno
industriale quindi dovevano essere
designer i miei alunni
il primo giorno di lezione gli dicevo
chi di voi ha passato almeno qualche
tempo con i nonni e fortemente
avvantaggiato e loro non capivano erano
designer progettavano cad rinascerò
progetti 3 di stampanti e e non capivano
perché io chiedessi questa cosa poi la
capivano alla fine del corso come prima
immagine li facevo vedere un profumo
famoso un'immagine di un profumo di un
sarto jean paul gautier è una lattina
forse la conoscete non l'ho portata
perché pensavo fosse una pubblicità è
una lattina dove dentro c'è una
silhouette di una donna e loro pensavano
è una è un'icona nei profumi a un'icona
pensavano chissà quali agenzie di
pubblicità si fossero messe a tirare
fuori quel lavoro ea capire come
come sfondare nel mercato e poi gli
raccontavo che quella latina era la
lattina con cui jean paul gautier
giocava con sua nonna per farlo stare
buono gli dava queste lattine e lui è
quella è qualcosa che è rimasto nel suo
dna creativo la nostra creatività ha un
dna ma io non voglio parlare di
creatività voglio parlare di artigianato
sono due mondi ben separati
c'è una creatività nell'artigianato
perché è quella che guida le sue mani ma
soprattutto c'è una storia c'è una
tradizione in questo momento il problema
più grande per me che faccio questo
lavoro e avere davanti due mondi un
mondo di giovani è un mondo di vecchi ma
quando dico vecchi dico veramente
vecchie persone di 80 90 anni depositari
di qualcosa che poi finirà non c'è un
modo per tramandare queste cose bisogna
stare vicino a loro bisogna stare a
bottega capire imparare usare le mani
usare le mani con la testa
questo non vuol dire fare dei falsi non
vuol dire riprodurre qualcosa che è
vecchio perché se quella cosa la
riproduce un ragazzo sarà comunque
diversa perché è filtrata dalla sua
esperienza
la settimana scorsa ho passato tre
giorni con i makers i makers sono i
nuovi artigiani gli artigiani digitali
usano la stampante 3d fanno protesi che
costano un decimo di quelle che che
pagano che si pagano comunemente questo
vuol dire che la specie si evolve
non è che l'artigiano è sempre col
ricama cuce o usa degli attrezzi
comunque che sono arcaici l'artigiano si
evolve usa una stampante l'importante è
la testa artigianale quella che io
sostengo è proprio questa intelligenza
artigianale l'intelligenza artigianale
e data ce l'abbiamo tutti ce l'abbiamo
nel momento in cui cuciniamo in cui
facciamo il cambio dell'armadio e che
abbiamo dove mettere le cose c'è una
logica in quello che facciamo in più noi
abbiamo anche una tradizione abbiamo un
dna siamo vissuti insieme a qualcuno che
ha fatto delle cose
se siamo stati capaci di assimilarle di
riportarle siamo ricchi abbiamo un
patrimonio e di questo patrimonio di cui
io vorrei parlare è un patrimonio
forse allora un po anacronistico sono
anni che io sento parlare del sostegno
che va dato ai giovani i giovani sono
importantissimi
dico sempre che un senso di colpa
fortissimo nei confronti dei giovani per
aver ricostruito un mondo che poi non è
così perfetto anzi di aver scaricato su
di loro per un danno un eredità negativa
però nello stesso tempo mi rendo conto
che c'è un problema di ascolto di saper
ascoltare in questo momento il mio
problema grosso sono il contatto fra gli
artigiani e questi che io chiamo gli
archivi umani gli archivi umani sono
delle figure come questi artigiani che
vi dicevo che non meno dei pesci che
abbiamo visto nell'acqua parliamo di
persone stanno scomparendo
potremmo fare delle magliette con le
facce 6 scomparendo
ho conosciuto persone che erano disposte
a regalare il loro il loro laboratorio
pur che qualcuno lo portasse avanti i
ragazzi non sono attratti da questo non
c'è nessun tipo di fascinazione nel fare
questo lavoro sono attratti dalla cucina
perché per un sacco di tempo gli abbiamo
fatto vedere che fare il cuoco è una
cosa intrigante è il talento naturale
che dobbiamo coltivare il talento
naturale lo vediamo tutti i giorni
io vedo in continuazione programmi in
cui si parla di talento naturale gare di
cucina gare di canto c'è un problema
reale in quello che invece sono le
professioni vere le professioni in
questo momento sono troppo rigide e non
si adattano un sistema che sta in
cambiamento
se dovessimo fare una foto del nostro
momento del mondo in cui viviamo non
possiamo metterla a fuoco non c'è niente
al fuoco stiamo in movimento siamo
esposti in spostamento da un mondo ad un
altro che il rapporto c'è fra l'anziano
che rapporto c'è fra
la stampante 3d è invece la persona che
vuole lasciare il suo laboratorio
c'è un rapporto di ascolto fra una
persona e l'altra c'è un sentire
mettersi in contatto e cercare di
tradurre quello che ci viene raccontato
in qualcosa di contemporaneo quello è il
segreto è l'unico segreto allora questi
archivi umani che io ho conosciuto in
varie forme in forme eccellenti come
persone uno per per citarlo giovanni è
l'archivio del magazzino del teatro
dell'opera il magazzino al teatro
dell'opera e qui fuori più vicino ci
sono diecimila costumi giovanni sa a
memoria dove sono tutti i costumi chi li
ha fatti perché li ha fatti e quando li
ha fatti quando morirà giovanni noi non
sapremo dove saranno i costumi andrà
tutto assolutamente perso è una memoria
di testa questo significa molto
semplicemente il mio invito
ma ripeto a livello proprio umano
quotidiano abbiamo parlato abbiamo
ascoltato di cose meravigliose che ci
uniscono tutti perché sono cose che
portano a vivere in un modo diverso ma
c'è una vita eccezionale c'è una
straordinaria amministrazione c'è
un'ordinaria amministrazione anche è una
propensione a cambiare perché detta così
sembra facile sì ma io che c'entro con
stampanti 3d con l'artigiano che fa le
cose
quello che vi invito a fare cambiare
anche il tipo di spesa che farete domani
ma non perché le cose sono migliori o
peggiori ma semplicemente a cambiarla
cambiate quello che mettete nel carrello
provate a cucinare un'altra cosa
provate ad ascoltare gli altri se un
fenomeno musicale italiano in questo
momento importantissimo e l'orchestra di
piazza vittorio dove suonano delle
persone che si sono unite solo perché
c'è un'affinità creativa di altri paesi
di altri luoghi quello diventa un
simbolo
nello stesso modo noi grazie alla rete e
la rete di cui abbiamo parlato è un
lavoro artigianale anche quello possiamo
metterci in contatto
possiamo parlare con altre persone che
fanno lo stesso tipo di prodotto in uno
dei delle manifestazioni che io pur
operai
abbiamo abbiamo fatto vedere che c'era
una tecnica di ricamo che andava
scomparendo
era un richiamo fatto con i nastri non
c'è più non si fa più le due persone che
lo fanno guadagnano quello che vogliono
in questo momento non è vero che lo
fanno tutti i giorni si parla di
prodotti eccezionali però ad una delle
due è stato raccontato da questa signora
anziana romana e questa ragazza una
ragazza rumena che ha avuto il tempo di
ascoltare di stare vicino a questa
persona in questo momento ho aperto una
scuola la scuola non ha sufficienti
posti in questo momento per accogliere
tutte le persone che si vogliono
iscrivere questa è una storia ma
un'altra storia importante la storia di
un altro ragazzo vi ho conosciuto era
convinto di essere un artista aveva
studiato all'accademia di belle arti
poi mi è stato presentato da un altro
artista e aveva fatto una borsa una
borsa di alluminio di moda non ne sa
niente assolutamente niente questa era
la sua salvezza ha fatto la borsa perché
il padre lavora all'alluminio da sempre
da 40 anni e lui da quel laboratorio da
quelle industria c'era solo passato poi
ha fatto questo oggetto in questo
momento queste borse sono vendute tanto
sono sono pezzi unici
quelli sono veri pezzi unici l'artigiano
può fare un pezzo unico e il mondo a noi
chiede piatti unici ma non pezzi unici
perché hanno una marca sopra pezzi unici
perché sono irripetibili
allora quando ho cercato delle immagini
per raccontare questa storia per
invitarvi a fare la spesa in un modo
diverso a creare in un modo diverso
quella che è la vostra giornata il
vostro tempo e lavoro
nostra vita avevo selezionato
inizialmente attrezzi figure di
artigiani mani che cucivano poi ho
capito che il mio invito maggiore era
proprio cercare di chiedervi di
ascoltare questi archivi umani che
scherzando io dico che si nascondono non
sono visibili l'incontrare sui treni in
quei tragitti in quelle soste forzate vi
raccontano un pezzetto di storia che è
la stessa cosa che ascoltavamo prime una
piccola cosa deve andare da qualche
parte deve deve essere uno stimolo a
produrre a cercare la prima immagine
tutte queste immagini che alla fine ho
scelto selezionato sono tratte da un
film
e con questo vorrei appunto concludere
questo film si chiamava ogni cosa è
illuminata e la storia di un ragazzo che
prima e bambino dal rapporto con la
nonna e con i nonni riceve qualcosa
labbra è un simbolo per me perché dentro
c'è un seme cioè lo stesso seme di prima
c'è qualcosa che viene dal passato è
lontanissimo ma è rimasto dentro di noi
si dice addirittura che l'ambra sia
curativa e molto importante per me
questo film perché racconta sintetizza
il potere della ricerca per costruire
una storia se ogni giorno da un archivio
dal dalla vita quotidiana noi prendiamo
qualcosa che è diverso dal lavoro dal
lavoro che facciamo possiamo costruire
un percorso ma soprattutto soprattutto
la ricerca di qualcos'altro
la ricerca di qualcos'altro che è una
storia è la storia per essere molto
molto banali dei nostri nonni la stessa
storia che chiedevo ai miei studenti
è un albero genealogico della nostra
creatività artigianale e potete
riportare su tutto ci sono delle io odio
la plastica abbiamo visto adesso ma la
odio la plastica per un motivo molto
preciso che la plastica ha portato a una
fine del mondo artigianale a uno stampo
a una produzione industriale che ha
limitato la creatività in questo momento
tutto il mondo guarda all'italia come a
qualcuno che ancora può raccontare
questo fatto a mano
vi ripeto la cosa più bella è che non è
un potere che abbiamo solo noi